we were talking about Larry Sanders Show
yesterday and I've been watching and
I've been binging the Larry Sanders Show
it's on HBO and if you get a chance it's
Garry Shandling and if it's just
brilliant and and what they did to give
you they pulled the curtain back and let
you see what was happening on late-night
TV and you know this fake late-night TV
host and Hank Kingsley is on there and
ripped or him it's just brilliantly done
and you know you start to look at the
credits and Judd Apatow's names there
and then all of a sudden we're gone so
three of the top 100 shows like you'll
find Judd involved in that freaks and
geeks a rolling stone at the top 100
shows i said to Fritzi i said reach out
to judge see if you join us even if it's
just talking about Larry Sanders but
prior to the commercial break we wanted
to know what Judd would watch on TV when
he would binge watch Judge joins us now
Judd thanks for joining us on short
notice and can you tell us the shows
that you watch that are not related to
the shows that you're involved in this
is a good question I've been doing a lot
of binging I don't know how I feel about
pinching or I'll tell you why because
it's too long between the season so you
watch your show you'll watch the whole
series in two days and then it comes
back in a year and then suddenly like
Marcos season two is on and i'm like
Escobar was he a good guy I forgot
though I like him if I like that guy is
he evil as the wife good and that I
forget I forget everything that I don't
think you forgot if escobar was a good
guy or not but I she was watching season
two of a great show called broadchurch
and in the Bill of episode for my wife
and I turned to each other and went I
think we watched this whole but your
aunt i binge watching you know what I
feel I'm for binging I do it I'm just I
just I don't know if I should wait till
the whole series is over and then just
been just series but you know what I
found judd with the night of with john
turturro on HBO yeah you had to wait a
week to get the next episode and we're
it's so foreign to us now because we're
used to watching house of cards and
watching it in three days I i looked for
word to that show because I had to wait
a week like we used to do when we were
growing up yeah I mean it's funny
because I do both I'm you know I work on
girls for HBO and it comes out every
week and it's really fun that everyone
fights about it and there's like a
conversation in the culture about what
Lena has done in the episode and then I
also do this show love on netflix and
people i think most people watch that
show in one sitting they watch it like a
five hour movie which is what I've
always wanted to make now do you watch
Deadliest Catch or House Hunters
International or diners drive-ins and
dives those kind of things I'm not
really a big you know looking at
people's storage spaces type of reality
guy I'll do a hoarders because I am a
hoarder and then I watch it and when
someone says I do want to throw away
that punching bag that's all torn up I'm
like don't throw it away you can fix it
what are you hoard hood right hoard you
know I always say my wife I go I'm a
hoarder but I only heard good stuff of
course daughters you get rid of all the
bad stuff well it's like we were making
this movie funny people and I remembered
that I used to videotape Adam sale
they're making phony phone calls when we
were kids and then I went in my little
[ __ ] d storage space and there it was
so it was valuable all the hoarding was
worthwhile just because everyone's I
find something that I need well there's
there's a g-rated Sandman and then
there's an x-rated Sandman right I I
enjoyed them both I mean I you know I
love those albums the really filthy out
of Santa records you know medium pace
and stuff like that and he's been
touring the country a lot lately and he
has a whole new set of songs that are so
great you know we perform it this place
called largo in los angeles all the time
and people should go see him live
because it's a real treat we I mentioned
the Larry Sanders Show and I remember
watching it when it first came on and I
just I loved it now we look back you
know I don't know how many years it's
been but Jeremy pivens on there you know
what Hank Kingsley is done yeah I mean
there's been there's been a lot of I'm
glad it came back
because you get us you get a chance to
really revisit what Larry was still in
Garry Shandling was doing but when you
first started on that show what did you
what were the expectations of it uh well
I was doing the Ben Stiller show for Fox
at the same time Gary was putting
together the Larry Sanders Show and Gary
would show me all of the audition tapes
I remember so clearly him showing me
Jeffrey Tambor's audition and saying
what do you think of this guy because he
was thinking about someone else but then
he saw jeffrey and i loved jeffrey from
when he was in uh and he was on Hill
Street Blues is a crazy judge and then
he was also in the albertina movie and
justice for all yeah and I was like this
is like my favorite character actor of
all time and I remember that when the
show aired this always baby laughs
Carrie worked so hard on it and then it
was the premiere of The Larry Sanders
Show there's no party there's nothing
you Carrie said hey you want to come
over and watch a show I go over to his
house I assume there's gonna be a group
of people there no one is there is a
load watch but doesn't that that fits
who gary was who Larry Sanders was
absolutely just watching the show with
me and and it was great you know Gary
had a very specific vision that he
brought everything that was happening
with the talk shows was so crazy that we
should do a show about the behind the
scenes of it and then it got crazier as
he was doing this show and then suddenly
he was offered all the talk shows so
Gary actually turned down all these 2 12
30 slots because he said that he would
rather make fun of it let's do it my
favorite one was David Duchovny oh yeah
can you how would you explain it well I
think he was talking to David about
doing the show and David said I think I
should have a man crush on you and they
just loved writing those scenes David
really involved in raikos seams and then
in the the finale there's this moment
where they're talking and Larry's
wearing a bathrobe and every time he
leans over to get something it's clear
that you can see if his balls something
the Cubbies trying to get a look which
which I think came about because you
know you would go hang out with Rodney
Dangerfield and he used always wear a
bathrobe after the show and what do you
wanted to see something or not you were
gonna say something yeah actually the
company's got the bathrobe on Larry is
cringing because yeah he thinks duchovny
actually is coming on to him and he goes
to his hotel room to say you know hey
I'd really like for you to be on the
show and then he has that Sharon Stone
moment before the Sharon Stone moment
where he uncross as his legs and larry
has that look of panic and discussed on
it yeah I loved it but now the top 10
where does it that I was getting so open
eyeballs it was and you probably helped
write it okay help me with the Rolling
Stone top 100 you had three shows in
there so Larry Sanders girls and freaks
and geeks yes now are you allowed to
vote for your own show uh exclusively
well congratulations I'm put in the best
healers oh I'm putting in undeclared I'm
putting in love I got a new show hasn't
aired yet with Pete Holmes called
crashing I'm like maybe I already should
be on the list for that did you consider
Sports Center as one of the top 100 TV
shows of all time that's very
interesting I thought we were kind of a
scripted universe well we experience
maybe I made a mistake maybe I could
have put these SportsCenter commercials
in there you like those oh my gosh those
are some funny commercials over those
over the many years yeah why didn't
Kennedy did an unbelievable job and you
know what was great is they just came in
observed as for two weeks and then they
left in wrote scripts and then they came
back and said just trust us and you know
we did I like the LeBron chair
commercial goes the throne yeah with
been held yeah
uh that was a great one are you on
Broadway are you doing something on
Broadway well there's a friend of mine
named Chris Gethard he has a talk show
that it's called the chris gethard show
that many people may have seen it's
really really funny you probably could
just search for it on youtube now and
he's had people like will ferrell at
maria bamford on its really great and he
has this one-man show that's all about
his mental illness and alcoholism and
suicide attempts and it's called career
suicide and it's really funny but it's
also just about how he has worked his
entire life to manage it and get his
head together and it said the Lynn
Redgrave theater you can get tickets at
a career suicide show calm and it got a
rave today in the New York Times it's a
really funny touching one man show about
his life and I recommend all to see it
it's the first time I've gotten behind a
show like this a live show so if you
like what I do I think you'd really like
this well I'm glad for you because you
needed a hit and you know I'm really
happy for you judge cuz you i'm just
trying to stay in the business you know
yeah you gotta got it pretty tough you
know did you see me throw the first the
ball out threw out the first pitch at
the mets game know how did it go it did
not go well it didn't go full you know
50 cent or press or the president's bad
was it was it like Baba Booey it was I
Baba Booey but i have to say that Baba
Booey was so in my head that I was
terrified the whole time you know I go
to the field to practice oh no and one
out of three is going Baba Booey during
the practice so I know I got a one out
of three of that happening and then I
meet the Mets and I'm very nervous
around athletes because i'm a nerd I was
only comfortable around mr. Matt because
me and him were in the same business or
entertainers and then I go they say okay
go out to the mound and I go out to the
mound I expect the audience to cheer
note here when my name is said lack of
interest and all I've done and then I
don't know what to do i'm just on the
mound and no one is around
I thought someone would explain how it
was going to go down and no one's around
I look and I see Jacob degrom in the
outfield like waiting for this to be
over and then I won't run over to him to
say hello and I don't realize you're not
supposed to do that like he's got his
game face on he's like Ali about to
fight Frazier and I'm like high pitch
and he looked at me like you're not
supposed to talk to me and then I got
nervous and I just he's dead dead center
very straight but the catcher did have
to walk forward to receive the ball he
poor thing hey good luck with a career
suicide show go to career suicide
show.com for tickets he's Judd Apatow
Judd thanks for joining us great to talk
to you again great my pleasure to see
you guys the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience